مخططا من خلال ساعات القادمه في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض مؤتمر التعديل الدولي
وحظي المؤتمر الدولي بمشاركه عدد من
الوراء و13
كما شهد توقيع عشرات الاتفاقيات لشركات
المحليه وخارجيه منها اعلان وشراكه لتاسيس
شركه الاستثمار في اصول التعدين دوليه بين
صندوق الاستثمارات العامه وشركه معه
زميل سالم الراجح ياخذنا في رحله بالارقام
عن مؤتمر التعدين الدولي في الرياض
متغيرات كبيره يعيشها العالم نحو الثروه
الطاقه والمعادن هنا في الرياض اجتمع
الالاف من انحاء العالم لمناقشه مستقبل
المعادن والطاقه المتجدده في المنطقه
والعالم اثنى عشر الف مشارك من 130 دوله
و200 متحدث من خبراء ومختصين ناقشوا
وتوسعه نطاق الثروات المعدنيه ومستقبلها
ومستجداتي قطاع الطاقه وغيرها من الملفات
على مداري يومين وخلال النسخه الثانيه من
مؤتمر التعدين الدولي ابرمت اكثر من 60
اتفاقيه بين جهات محليه ودوليه ابرز تلك
الشركات مشاهدينا اتفاقيه مشروع مشترك بين
الصندوق الاستثمارات العامه وشركه معادن
لتاسيس شركه للاستثمار في الاصول
التعدينيه براس مال يبلغ
2007 287 مليون ريال
وتنص الاتفاقيه على التزام شركه معادن
وصندوق الاستثمارات العامه بتمويل الشركه
بمبلغ اجمالي يلامس اثني عشر مليار عند
الحاجه اذا مستقبل واعد جدا للتعدين في
السعوديه هذا ما اكده وزير الصناعه
السعودي بندر الخريف خلال المؤتمر الخريف
قال ان المسح على الجيولوجي كشف عن كميات
كبيره من المعادن تقدر بخمسه ترليونات
ريالا سعودي
ايضا من الرياض مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن
الحربي من مطار مؤتمر التعدين اهلا عبد
المحسن
لما الذي انتهى اليه المؤتمر
في ساعات
الختاميه تجري نقاشات ورش عمل خلال هذا
خلال هذا الوقت قبيله انعقاد او انتهاء
هذا المؤتمر في عام ثانيه الذي اصبح رقما
صعبا في المؤتمرات التعدين الدوليه وجذب
الكثير من
المستثمرين والمسؤولين المختصين في
التعدين حول العالم المؤتمر ركز على منطقه
وسط وغرب اسيا وكذلك افريقيا فبالتالي
شاهدنا عدد كبير جدا من هذه المنطقه قدموا
بالاضافه الى همم اعداد اخرى قدمت تتحدث
عن وزراء من بريطانيا من دول مختلفه حضروا
لعقد الشركات لمناقشه ابرز التطورات
والتحديات التي تواجه قطاع التعديل لتصبح
السعوديه وهذه المنصه تحديدا واحده من اهم
المنصات عالميا في قطاع التعديل للمناقشات
العالميه وتطلع لرؤى مستقبليه في قطاع
التعذيب في الحقيقه تتحدث اكثر في المؤتمر
مع همم نائب وزير الصناعه والثروه
المعدنيه المهندس خالد المديفر الذي
سيحدثنا عن هذا المؤتمر فيكم مهندس خالد
حدثنا في البدايه عن المؤتمر في ختامي في
عام الثاني الذي حققه وما هي ابرز همم
الاهداف من هذا المؤتمر
خالد الاستديو الحقيقه انت موجود معنا
يمكن شفت الحراره وشفت
المستوى التمثيل العالمي العدد كبير ولله
الحمد ولكن الاهم من العدد والمستوى اللي
بشركات عالميه وتجميع دوله تجمع دولي يعدل
اكبر تجمع للوزراء ومختصاصين الحكوميين في
التعدين في العالم في التاريخ وليس فقط في
همم وهذا ما جعله المنصه الاساس كما سمعنا
اليوم من العديد من رؤساء الشركات من كبار
شركات العالميه عندنا من اكبر خمس شركات
في العالم اربع شركات موجودين معنا
وان شاء الله السنه الجايه كل كل الكبرى
شركات العالم 100% هيكونوا هنا لان هذا
المؤتمر
بحيويه المملكه في جاذبيه المملكه بالطاقه
التي
تمدنا بها الرؤيه اصبح الملتقى الاهم
بشهاده جميعك الكثير وجميع الرؤساء
الشركات اللي جمعناهم مهندس خالد ربما
ابرز ما يحدث الان هو ما يحدث في القاعه
التي خلفها وهو ملتقى الفرص تحدث عن سته
مواقع يتم طرح فيها فرص بلدي يحدث في هذه
القاعه المهندس هو ده همم اجتماع للدعوه
فقط الحقيقه كان عندنا تجربه جميله في
الخليجيه المملكه الجديده على التعدين
هناك كثير من الشركات والمؤسسات
ورجال الاعمال السعوديين المهتمين في
التعدين لانه قطاع جديد قطاع نامي قطاع
سيكون احد قطاعات الاساسيه المملكه ولكن
الخبرات
ليست منتشره في المملكه لذلك هذا الاجتماع
يجمع بين شركات اجنبيه ترغب بالشراكه
سعوديين ولديهم خبره
ومستثمرين سعوديين
يودون الاستثمار في التعدين في المملكه
هذا التجمع 24 شركه سعوديه 24 مستمر سعودي
و 27 شركه اجنبيه مهتمه في السماء في
السعوديه وتحتاج الى شريك سعودي فهذه ان
شاء الله يخرج منها تحالفات هذه تحالفات
ستقدم على المناقصات الجايه او تقدم
مباشره على المنصه هناك ست فرص في الطريق
وتم تحديدها في الذهب والفضه همم والنحاس
والزنك وكذلك في الحديد فكل هذه ان شاء
الله ينتج عنها شركات سعوديه تبدا من هذه
الغرفه ولكن ان شاء الله تكون بحجم عالمي
في السنوات القادمه في الجزيره المهندس
شكرا عبد المحسن شكرا اذا خالد كما تشاهد
ساعات الاخيره لانتهاء مؤتمر التعدين
الدولي الذي كان مخطط له بان يصبح واحد من
افضل خمسه مؤتمرات او اكبرها حول العالم
ولكنه سرعان ما اصبح الثاني على مستوى
العالم في عامه الثاني فبالتالي اهتمام
كبير جدا من قبل كافه المستثمرين في قطاع
التعديل حول العالم وليس فقط في الفرص
المطروحه في السعوديه ولكن حتى في
المواضيع التي يتم مناقشتها لا سيما
باستثمار
فرص الكبيره والحاجه الملحه همم المواد
التعديديه التي تستخدم في همم الطاقه
النظيفه ومنتجات ونتحدث عن السيارات
الكهربائيه وغيرها وكافه الصناعات الجديده
والنظيفه فبالتالي كان هنالك همم احاديث
كبيره حول
تطوير هذه
الصناعات او حتى المساهمه في توفير هذا
الكم الهائل من الطلب المتوقع خلال اعوام
القليله القادمه الاسيمه وان كثير من
الدول
تطمح لان تصل الى صفر انبعاثات كربونيه
فبالتالي هذه المعادن مهمه جدا على مستوى
العالم وهما تم طرحه خلال ايام المؤتمر
الثلاثه خالد شكرا لك من الرياض مراسل
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي